[Music]
hello it's Saturday and I thought I'd
take a vlog today so we're about to head
out and go get some bunch with some
friends and then afterwards probably
gonna come back and work on a video and
code a little bit so yeah hope you enjoy
[Music]
hey friends yeah it's just kind of like
chilling this Saturday night I don't
have any big plans this is a pretty like
typical Saturday Sunday at this point at
least with for like the last two months
it has been I've been trying to like not
plan so many things during the weekend
maybe doing like one or two things so
that I have time to like relax clean and
take care for myself and then also work
on YouTube stuff work on my side project
and it's been working out pretty well
pretty proud of where it's been I just
didn't like stay consistent with it and
I think this month I've fallen a little
bit off the boat so just kind of like
keep going and make sure that I keep up
with everything basically so pretty
confident I can do it all hopefully my
vlog cameras gonna come on a Monday and
mail cuz I'm actually using like my big
rig right now and I'm really excited for
this block should be a lot easier to
vlog so hopefully there will be more
vlogs like this but yeah let me know if
you liked this vlog it was a little more
chattier than the last one
hopefully it's fun to watch as well
it's so cold in the Bay Area I'm
freezing but it's also like 40 to 50
degrees so you know everything's
relative but it's cold 40 or 63 degrees
is cold it is though so